[Music]
hey friends and welcome to introduction
to angular and google i o 2022 we're
thrilled to have you here and i for one
can't wait to get started with today's
workshop introduction to angular
angular is a framework designed to
support developers as they build
scalable web applications whether it's
scaling your product as user demand
increases or scaling your team to meet
growing technical needs angular will
continue to be a fantastic solution in
this workshop we're going to build an
angular application from the ground up
called fair house
fairhouse is an app that lists housing
locations for individuals or families
facing housing and security
here's a preview of what we'll be
building together today
now here's what you'll need to get
started node the angular cli and the
starter project from github
since this workshop is based on the
introduction to angular code lab you can
find the links in all of the details at
this url
be sure to complete all of the setup
instructions before continuing along
with me now i'll be using vs code and
the angular language service plugin for
vs code for the best development
experience
with that done let's get into it alright
friends i have my editor vs code open
with my project already loaded and a
blank chrome window
let's confirm that the application
starter code is working by starting up
angular's dev server here's how we do
that
in the terminal window type the
following command ng server
in the browser navigate to localhost
4200 and it should display the text
fairhouse app is running if that's the
same content being displayed in your
browser then we're off to a good start
if you are unable to get this message to
display be sure that you have installed
the dependencies with npm and that you
are in the right folder these are two
common mistakes
ask me how i know
all right this is excellent your app is
up and running and we can move on to the
next step working with components
i pre-built this app with the ng-new
command provided by the angular cli
the angular cli is a command line tool
that provides features and utilities to
help boost your productivity when
building an angular application
when creating a new application the
angular cli scaffolds everything you
need to get started source code testing
setup and configuration files the source
code for the app can be found in the
source folder
there's a folder called app which
represents our component
this is a great segue into one of the
core concepts of angular components
components are the core building blocks
for angular applications
think of components as a brick used for
construction when starting out a brick
doesn't have much power but when
combined with other bricks we can build
incredible structures the same goes for
apps built with angular
each component has three main aspects
an html file for the template
a css style for the files
and a typescript file for the behavior
of the application
there are some other files in this
directory that we'll come back to later
but first we're going to update our ui
open
app.component.html in your editor and
delete all the code in that file
we're going to replace it with a main
tag then inside of the main tag we'll
add a header
the header tag will contain our logo and
the text fairhouse
we'll also add an empty section tag as a
sibling to the header tag
save this code and let's check the
browser with our development server
running the changes will be reflected in
the browser when we save next we want to
add a text field for search and a button
to the ui
now components have many benefits with
one of those being the ability to
organize the ui we're going to create a
component that will contain our text
field the button for search and
eventually the list of locations
to create this new component we'll use
the angular cli
from the command line
we'll type ng generate component housing
list
let's take a moment to explain the
command we just used ng is the angular
cli and g comes from the word angular
generate tells the cli what type of
action we want to perform
in our case we want to generate
something
that something happens to be a component
we can generate other things like
classes routes enums and more
check out the documentation for ng
generate to find out more
finally we'll pass the name as the last
argument to this command
we want to call our component housing
list i'm naming it that because we'll
eventually put the filtered list of
options there
after hitting enter to execute the
command the output of the command is
displayed in the terminal letting us
know what just happened in our case
multiple files were created for us the
typescript class the html template and
the css file
in the folder tree there's been an
update to the source app folder
now we have a housing list folder which
contains all of those files we just
covered
next we need to add this new component
to our ui
back in
app.component.html let's update the
section tag and add our newly created
component app housing list
if the refresh doesn't happen
automatically check for errors in the
terminal also check to make sure that
the development server is still running
the updated ui now reads fair house
and housing list works
let's update the housing list component
with the code for the input field and
the button
in housinglist.component.html
i'm going to remove the existing code
here and add a label
input and the button
now before we go back to the browser
let's update the styles for this
component i've already written them we
just have to add them to the application
in housing list component.css
copy the styles from the codelab and
paste them into this file
we'll save the code here and the ui will
be updated
okay can you believe all this great
progress that we're making here this is
fantastic
we have the input and the button but
clicking on them doesn't do anything
and we can fix that
on the web when we want to interact with
controls like buttons we have to invoke
the use of click handlers
angular has support for click handlers
built in as well
so first we'll handle the button see
what i did there we'll make these
changes in housinglist.component.html
to add a click handler
we'll need to add the event listener to
the button first in angular the syntax
is to surround the name of the event in
parentheses
and assign it a value
the parentheses let angular know that
the attribute click is meant to be an
event
let's take care of the value to the
right hand side of the equal sign
here we'll name the function that will
be called when the button is clicked
let's call it search housing locations
and don't forget to add the parentheses
to the end of this function to call it
once we save our code the browser will
have an error letting us know about a
compilation error
the search housing locations method
doesn't exist in our typescript class
for this component remember
the typescript class contains the logic
for our components we have to implement
search housing locations
let's take care of that now
in housinglist.component.ts
we have the component decorator
detailing what the tag name should be
for this component the location of the
template for this component and the
location of the styles for this
component
in the body of the class we'll add the
implementation for the function
i'm going to add a new line and add the
function signature for search housing
locations
saving this code the browser will update
to reveal an app with no more
compilation errors again we're back at
it with more great progress i am so
proud of you
our next step is to somehow get the
value of the input field and pass it in
as an argument to the search housing
locations method
we're going to use an angular feature
called a template variable this allows
us to get a reference from the html
element from a template and interact
with it in this case we're going to get
a reference to the input and then send
the value as an argument to the method
and housinglist.component.html
let's add an attribute called search
within hashtag as a prefix to the input
next we'll add an argument to the search
housing locations method called
search.value
the search.value is the reference to the
input and the value property of the
input
one cool thing about template variables
is that they can be used throughout the
template in this case i'm using it to
send it the value from the input
into the function but
there are also more use cases to
consider
in
housinglist.component.cs
we need to update the method signature
for search housing locations to include
a stream parameter called search text
we'll add that in the parentheses
of the function signature
we're using typescript and one of the
big value adds of typescript is type
checking the type checking allows
developers to write safer code at
compile time
we want the type of the search text to
be a string
we'll add a colon and the string type
now search text has to be a string if it
is anything else
we'll get an error so this is what we
want to ensure that the code is
functioning as we'd hope
let's add something to let us know that
the code is working
that could be a test but for now we're
going to use our age-old friend
console.log
i'm going to add console.log of search
text to the body of the search housing
locations method
save all the code
and in the browser open up chrome dev
tools and navigate to the console tab
enter a value in the input field any
value will be fine i'm going to enter
chicago and when i click enter
we find that the console now displays
chicago or whatever value you entered
all right that was awesome can you
believe all that great progress that
we've made so far you deserve something
special again
here's another high five from me to you
so far we've created a new component use
a template variable to get a reference
to an element in our template and
updated our typescript class and
template to include an event handler we
are making wonderful progress let's keep
going
while this is very cool we need to get
some data involved our application
should show a filtered list of housing
locations based on the search criteria
so here's what we want to represent
each location has a string property for
name city state
photo and number property for available
units and two boolean properties one for
laundry and one for wi-fi
we could represent this as a plain java
object but one of angular strength is
the adoption of types and typescript
using types helps us avoid errors during
build time so we're going to make a type
for our housing location
in the terminal of the editor we can use
the angular cli to create the housing
location type to do this we type ng
generate
interface
housing location
we use interface to shape the data in
typescript
this is a best practice versus creating
classes you can find out more in the
official typescript documentation
in
housinglocation.ts
we can add the type details for our
interface we'll give each property the
appropriate type based on our design
in app.component.ts
we're going to create an array
containing the data that represents our
housing locations
first we'll import the housing location
interface from dot slash housing
location
then in the body of app component class
let's add a property to the class called
housing location list
the type of this property is an array of
type housing location
we'll also add a few simple locations to
start with
this is where shaping the data works in
our favor while we don't have to
instantiate new instances of a class we
can still take advantage of the type
information provided by the interface
the data in our objects has to be the
same shape
or match the properties defined on the
interface
now we need a way to share this data
with other parts of our application
other components
normally
this data will be stored in another
class and then we can use it in multiple
places but here we'll just make this
happen by sending the data into housing
list component
via the angular input feature
we can add the input decorator to a
property and pass the value via the
template
let's implement this change to get more
clarity on how this works
in housing list component.ts
we have to import input from angular
core as well as housing location from
one level up slash housing location
next we create a property called
location list in the body of the
component class we're going to use input
as a decorator for location list
to learn more about declarators please
check out the angular documentation at
angular.io
now i'm going to create this right above
the constructor we're setting the type
of this property to be an array where
the elements are of type housing
location
in app.component.html
let's update the app housing list
element we're going to include an
attribute called location list
in camelcase and set the value equal to
housing location list
the location list attribute has to be
surrounded in square brackets so that
angular can dynamically bind the value
of the locationless property to a
variable or expression otherwise angular
will treat the value to the right hand
side of the equals as a string
this is not the energy that we're
looking for now if you're getting any
errors at this point check out the
following ensure that the input
attribute name spelling matches the
spelling in the property of the
typescript class case matters here as
well
ensure that the property name on the
right hand side of the equals is spelled
correctly
also make sure that the input property
is surrounded by square brackets
let's confirm that we're sharing data
from the app component
to the housing list component
we're going to display all of the
locations in the location list on the
housing list component
we could hard code this but since we
have an array and we want to display
each of the items the best solution is
some sort of looping mechanism
to do that
we'll make use of the angular template
feature called ng4
this allows us to repeat some of the
html content in our templates
in housing list component.html
let's update the template to display the
data in the browser beneath the input
and the buddy controls we're going to
add an article element
inside the article element we'll add the
ng4 but don't forget the asterisk
in g4
equals
let
location
of location list
this code we're adding is called
template syntax and is an angular
feature you can learn more about
template syntax in the angular
documentation
here location is like a local variable
that we can use in our template within
of the scope of the article element so
that means between the opening and
closing tags of the article
next we'll display some values from the
location remember each location here is
one of our housing list locations from
the app component
let's add a p element and the title that
p element will be interpolated values
from the location property
in angular templates we can use
interpolation to display values via the
curly bracket syntax let's do that now
as a child of the p tag we add double
curly brace
location.name
closing double curly brace
save this so that the updates can also
be made in the browser
okay great the browser now has the
content of the updated templates the
data is being shared from the app
component to the housing list component
and we're iterating over each of those
values to display them in the browser
very cool
we've just covered some ways to share
data between components
use some new template syntax and the ng4
directive
we need to make some further updates to
our housing list component the filter
function isn't exactly working because
we haven't implemented that part of the
functionality
let's take that step now
what we want to happen is for the search
results to only include locations that
match our criteria when the user clicks
the search button in
housinglist.component.cs we are going to
make some changes
first let's add a new property called
results and set the value to be an array
of type housing location
in the search housing locations method
let's update the code to filter the
results based on the search text
let's remove the console.log and assign
the results property the value of the
location list that's been filtered by
location city
let's remove the console.log and assign
the results property the value of
location list being filtered by location
city
we'll make sure to compare the lowercase
version of the search text
and location city property
you
it's worth taking time to mention that
when referencing properties of a class
inside the methods that we have to use
to this prefix
that's why we're using it with this dot
results and this dot location list
we can improve our code just a bit if
the search text value is blank we
shouldn't try to filter let's add a
guard at the top of our function if
search text is blank return
our method has been updated to handle
the filter let's update the template as
well in housinglist.component.html
we just need to replace the location
list with results
in the ng4
be sure to save all the code and now
let's check the browser
we can type a value into the search
field and confirm that the search
results match depending on how many
locations are in a given city
all right this is working great so far
excellent work
before we move on remember that this is
the first iteration of our code
right now we can search by location but
we can expand this code to search across
the various fields if we wanted
once we're done with this workshop if
you want to implement that functionality
that could be a great way to continue
your angular journey
all right we just finished implementing
the core functionality of our location
search there's just one more piece of
the puzzle remaining and then will be
functionally complete from here
we just need to implement the details
panel that should display after a user
clicks on the search results let's get
to it
in order to implement the details
display functionality we'll need to make
it possible for users to click on a
search result
the housing list component knows which
detail was clicked and since we're going
to display the details in the parent
component we need a way to share the
data from the child component
up to the parent component
now we use the input decorator to share
data from the parents of the
child to share from the child to the
parent we use the output decorator and
the event emitter let's update the code
to get this communication working in our
application
in housinglistcomponent.ts
need to import output and event emitter
from angular core
next we'll create a property called
selected location event and use the
output decorator and assign the value to
be a new event emitter of type housing
location
again types are going to help us because
we can have expectations of our code
when the selected location event is
handled the code can expect some data of
type housing location
and that's opposed to something
unpredictable
so what's next in this process
well we'll need to trigger the location
selected event whenever a user clicks on
a location from the list let's add that
code now underneath the search housing
locations method we'll add a new method
called select housing location and it'll
take a housing location as a parameter
then in the body of the method we'll
emit a new event from the location
selected event emitter
the value that we'll emit is the
location that was selected by the user
all right let's link this to our
template
in housinglist.component.html
let's update that article element once
again this time we're going to add a
button element as a child with a label
that reads view
and add a click event to it
we're going to set the value of the
click event to be
select housing location and pass in the
location variable from our ng4
this way every one of these repeated
items will be clickable and have a
reference to the correct location the
housing locations each have a button
that is now clickable and we know which
location has been clicked the final step
is to hook this up in our parent
component app component
over in
app.component.html
let's update the app housing list
element right now it has an input so
that we can send data to it from the
parent component
but it now has an event that we can
listen to in order to get values out of
the component so in our case the event
name is housing location selected which
is the same name as the event emitter
that we created in the
housinglist.component.ts file
the names should match years
and
since it is an event
we'll surround it with parentheses too
now
we should provide an event handler to
deal with the event when it happens
we'll call that event handler update
selected location and pass it the
special value of dollar sign event
the dollar sign event argument will be
an object of type housing location
because well that's what we set the
event emitter's type parameter to be
angular handles all of this part for us
we just need to confirm that our
templates are correct
we haven't implemented the update
selected location function yet so let's
do that in app.component.ts
we'll need to make two changes here
first we'll need to add a property
called selected location of type housing
location or undefined
then we'll add the update selected
location function which takes a
parameter of type
housing location
we have to allow for the selected
location to also include the undefined
type because we may not have a selected
location
now one way to get around this is to set
a default value
in the body of the function we'll set
the value of this dot selected location
to be
the parameter location
with this part complete
the last step is to update the template
to display the selected location
in
app.component.html we'll update the
template to add a sibling element to the
app housing list component
we'll add an article element and inside
that element we'll display the details
of our selected location
let's display the photo the name the
city and the rest of the properties
now we're going to use the optional
chaining operator when retrieving these
values because we don't know for sure
that the values are defined since the
selected location type
is housing location or undefined
if it turns out to be undefined then we
don't want our application to crash
that's not a good experience for the
user and for laundry and wi-fi we'll use
a bit more template syntax here and add
ternary expressions that will display a
more human readable message
has laundry does not have laundry and
has wi-fi does not have wi-fi
let's save the code and return to our
browser
if we search for a location and click
view
we can see the details
wow this app is looking awesome and we
have some great functionality but
there's a slight problem though
when the page first loads the ui has
some unexpected details being displayed
angular has some neat features that can
help us solve this issue and improve the
user experience but we'll do that in the
next step because right now i want to
celebrate
excellent work so far friends we've
really made some great progress on the
application
we can share data from the child
components to the parent components
using the output decorator and the event
emitter we've also successfully allowed
our users to enter a value search using
that value then display the results and
click view to see more details
that's incredible work
i wish i could give you a double high
five
let's clean up our templates and then
we'll be done building the fair house
application
the ui contains those artifacts because
we're displaying them no matter what
what we need to do is conditionally
display those details based on whether
or not the user has selected a housing
location
this is a perfect fit for the ng if
feature provided by angular
we'll use two angular features to solve
our issue
if we use the ngif directly on the
article element the ui will shift which
may lead to a poor user experience
let's wrap the details in an element
that we can show or hide in the ui
now we could use something like a div
element but that would add unnecessary
elements to our dom
angular has an element called nd
container that will not be rendered in
the final output but
we can add the ndf directive to it
let's update the code in
app.component.html
next add the ngf directive to the ng
container element we have to include the
asterisk here and set the condition to
be selected location
the contents of the ng container element
will only be displayed if
selected location is truthy
save this code and let's head to the
browser and confirm that the
functionality is what we expect
the page starts off with no search
results and no panel perfect
we'll search for a location then click
the view button and there it is our nice
details panel there's one final update
we can make to our application the
search results in
housinglist.component.html
should display more details
in
housinglist.component.html update the
code
to feature a few more details for each
location
save this code and confirm in the
browser that our beautiful application
is fully functional with a complete ui
wow wow wow can you believe this we just
built a feature complete version of our
web app i'm so proud of you and i see
that you did some great work here
we've just covered how to send events
and data from the child components to
the parent components the output
decorator and event emitter how to
conditionally display elements and
templates with ngif and how we can use
optional chaining operator and ternary
expressions in templates
we've created a beautiful functional
application that is ready for you to
extend and continue building
if you want to continue to build
functionality here are some ideas
the data is hardcoded in the application
a great refactor is to add a service to
contain the data
the details page is currently being
displayed on the same page but it would
be cool to move the details to their own
page and take advantage of angular's
router
one other update could be to host the
data at a rest endpoint and use
angular's http package to load the data
at runtime there's lots of opportunity
for fun
friends thanks so much for spending time
with me today building this angular
application we've had so much fun and
learned a lot
remember you can find this code in the
code lab and on github
you can continue your angular journey by
following us on twitter and youtube for
fresh angular content
until the next time
go build great apps
[Music]
you